Thanks to CuriosityStream for supporting this
episode!
Go to CuriosityStream.com/microcosmos to start
streaming thousands of documentaries and for
a special offer that helps support our show.
If you’ve been following along with us lately,
you probably know that we’re pretty excited
about our latest microscope upgrades.
And can you blame us?
It's like having a new toy that’s actually
a spaceship.
It’s pretty hard to shut up about something
that is shiny and new, and also takes you
into a whole new world.
And that’s kind of what it feels like to
see our familiar friends at this magnification.
Even though we’ve seen tardigrades many
times before, in so many different ways, we
have not seen them like this.
And bringing this level of magnification gives
us a new layer of the microcosmos to explore.
It’s like we’ve descended into a new level
of a cave, getting further from our world—though
fortunately for the easily scared among us,
the cave is metaphorical and the risks are negligible.
All we need for the journey are some objective
lenses and a tiny drop of... oil?
Yeah, oil.
But to explain what that oil does, we’re
going to have to get a little technical first.
Because yes, we love our microbes, but we’re
only able to see them thanks to light, and
light is complicated, but we need to give
it its due.
So let’s start with the objective lens.
The main job of the objective lens is to take
light leaving the sample and focus it into
an image for the us to see.
And there are two main numbers that describe
the objective lens.
The first one’s pretty obvious: it’s the
magnification.
But the magnification you see written on the
objective lens is not the same as the magnification
we write up on the corner of the videos.
That’s because the objective lens isn’t
the only source of magnification in our microscope.
We’re also looking through an eyepiece that
has its own magnification.
So the final magnification that we see is
the product of the objective lens’ and eyepiece’s magnifications.
Now we don’t usually do math on this channel,
but this is one of the rare cases where the
math and optics is straightforward.
In our microscope, the eyepiece has a magnification
of 10x.
So if we’re looking through a 63x objective,
the final magnification is 630x.
And that is the number you’ll see in the
corner.
But you should never trust an optics lesson
that seems simple.
How could it be when the image we’re seeing
is the product of so many things at once,
some tangible like a lens, others much less
so.
And what is less tangible than light, which
is, as we’ve seen before on this channel--a
very strange thing.
We cannot touch it, but we can manipulate
it, using what we know of the way it travels
and bends and reflects to see our world differently.
But light… has its limits.
The thing about making things larger is that
at some point, it’s not enough to just zoom in.
You need to be able to capture the detail
that’s there.
And this leads to the second important number
you’ll find on an objective lens: the numerical aperture.
Unlike magnification, “numerical aperture”
is probably not super self-explanatory.
What the number describes is the ability of
the objective to take in light.
As light travels from the sample and to the
objective, it radiates outwards like a cone.
The higher your numerical aperture, the wider
the cone of light that's going into your objective.
And that allows for more rays to enter the
objective from all sorts of different angles,
helping to illuminate more details and give
greater resolution to your final image.
But of course, that’s still not all that
goes into capturing the perfect microscopic image.
Let’s take a look at this glaucoma spinning
around at 1000x magnification.
It’s visible, and you can see some of the
details.
It looks…fine.
But let’s take a look at it again here.
Same glaucoma.
Same objective.
Same level of magnification.
What was “fine” before now just looks
dull in comparison to the image we were seeing
before with the detailed striations and vivid
pockets of green on the glaucoma’s body.
To get from one of these images to the other,
James—our master of microscopes—didn’t
change any of the technical settings on his
microscope or pull some kind of video editing wizardry.
He just simply added a drop of oil to the
coverslip encasing the glaucoma, and dipped
the objective into the oil.
Now this is because the cone of light going
from the specimen into the objective isn’t
just going straight from the sample to the
lens.
It’s passing through something—it’s
passing through air.
Light travels at different speeds through
different materials and when it changes from
material to material, it will bend.
This is called refraction and materials like
oil slow light down more.
And that matters to our microscope because
it gives us the wider cones of light we need
to get a higher numerical aperture.
Whether we’ve got air between the sample
and the lens or oil when we’re viewing our
samples depends on the objective we’re looking
through.
Our lower magnification objectives have lower
numerical apertures, and they’re meant to
be used with air.
Our higher magnification objectives have higher
numerical apertures, and they’re meant to
be used with oil.
Using air with oil objectives gives us poor
images, and using oil with our dry objective
would damage the objective.
So…don’t do that.
The numerical aperture and its relationship
to resolution is important because it puts
a limit on just how much magnification we
can actually do with a given objective.
There’s a general estimate if you are looking
into microscopy yourself, that you’ll get
a good magnification when you’re working
in the range that’s 500 to 1000 times the
numerical aperture of the objective.
So our 100x objective and 1.3 numerical aperture
can reach a maximum of 1300x magnification
depending on your eyepiece.
With our 10x eyepiece, we get 1000x magnification,
and it works great.
But if we tried to get more from this set-up
by increasing the magnification of our eyepiece
to 20x, we could not actually get 2000x magnification.
Because of the constraints of our numerical
aperture, we would just be losing half of
our image without actually gaining more detail
in what’s left to see.
But that’s what happens any time we want
to take an image: we have to make a decision
between what we can and cannot see.
There are always choices that have to be made,
and details that have to be lost.
We simply cannot see all of the world, in
all its entirety, all at once.
But we can see more of it by tracking the
choices we make as we dive deeper, choices
in techniques and materials that affect what
we can see and how we see it, and enrich the
story further, even when those choices impose
constraints.
At some point in history, we wanted to see
more, and lenses with their magnificent manipulation
of light have helped us do that.
We’ve used them to see light from distant
stars, and to peer into the most mundane surroundings
on earth.
And whatever image has come back to us has
brought the universe closer to view, even
if it’s just in fractions.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
This episode was brought to you by CuriosityStream,
a subscription streaming service that offers
thousands of documentaries and non­fiction
TV shows from some of the world's best filmmakers,
including award winning exclusives & originals.
They cover topics like history, nature, science,
food, technology, travel, and more!
There, you can watch the documentary series
“Ancient Yellowstone” where scientists
discuss how the distribution of microbial
life in extreme environments here on our planet
can give us a better idea of where in the
universe life might be able to exist.
You can stream CuriosityStream’s library,
including their collections of curated programs
handpicked by their experts, to any device
for viewing anytime, anywhere, and if you
go to curiositystream.com/microcosmos and
use the word “Microcosmos” to sign up,
it will only cost you $14.99 for an entire
year!
The people you’re seeing on the screen right
now, those are our Patreon patrons.
They are the people who help make this show
possible.
If you like it, they are the ones to thank.
And I am feeling very grateful for them today
as they allow us to look deeper, not just
in magnification, but also in resolution.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam & Germs on Instagram and also I think
TikTok now.
And if you want to see more from us, there’s
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.